la chroniqueuse power comme tous les
lundis Anthony une demi-heure à présent
consacrée uniquement au sport oui tout à
fait nous en rejoins sur ce plateau les
organisateurs de la course au castors
mais avant d'en parler avec vous de
cette course d'orientation qui qui aura
lieu ce week-end on va d'abord partir en
mer comme je le disais en sommaire
d'émission avec le Vendée Globe qui est
à largué les amarres ce week-end des
Sables-d'Olonne les 19 participants donc
sont partis et parmi les navigateur il y
a un versaillais il s'agit de tanguy de
Lamotte il concourt pour initiative cœur
une association qui soutient Mécénat
Chirurgie Cardiaque donc une noble cause
et vous découvrez à l'instant les toutes
premières images de sa navigation c'est
son premier Vendée Globe à 34 ans et
pour l'instant il pointe à la 16e place
pour la petite histoire tout va bien
tanguy de Lamotte reste prudent dans la
négation et il a fait son premier repas
hier soir je vais vous faire saliver
Wilfried il a mangé une soupe au
potimarron et ben la vie est belle voilà
il faisait beau en mer et en plus une
petite soupe au potimarron formidable et
nous l'aurons par téléphone la semaine
prochaine dans la chronique sport et on
fera un point sur le sport sur ces
résultats et sur cette compétition c'est
bien de savoir ce qu'il mange mais c'est
bien de savoir aussi comment ça se passe
pour lui côté compétition